Tụi bốc tạo trên hệ này, dịch nắp, soka như phẩm để chúng cơ hội nhân thường gấp một chăm lần.
Tụi bốc từ hiệu biệt cao cấp đến từ đan vật đặc khối đảo mạng xa hội với lần sống soka như phẩm qua trương trình quyết máy,
xanh thêm nắp, chúng cấp chăm.
Với cơ trẻ xanh nắp tụi vị người chơi có thể chúng cơ hội nhân một chăm lần giá thị dại thường,
đến năm triệu thành người tì đầu trong thích tắc.
Cơ trẻ gấp đặc hình thường đồng nhất của chương trình báo ôm hai loại nắp thường,
nắp tình báo thấp dẫn với nhiều mạnh giá từ với nghi đồng đến năm triệu đồng.
Nắp nhân thường với hệ số nhân hai, nhân ba và thật chiến nhân một chăm.
Khi dật chú nắp tình mặt kết hợp nắp nhân thường, hơi có thể nhận tổng dại thường tạo hệ số nhân thường.
Với hàng triệu đáp thường có tổng giá chị đến đến năm với tì đầu được tùng ra trên toàn quốc,
tù bốc năng tạo cơ hội cho các tự sản nắp soka mài mắn xem ai chú lớn hơn.
Và chỉ mới phải ngày sau khi chương trình khởi đồng.
Dạy thường đường đồng tình đã hỏi trên người chơi ở thành phố Binh Tình Gian.
Sau khi dật năm trước đồng, anh cao đăng hiểu tiếp tục hành trình xanh thiên nắp,
đỏ trên phẩm với các tả thứng để xem ai chú lớn nhất.
Ngay ngày hôm sau, anh đã dật chú nắp trên thiên một chăm lần khi uống thu hốc ai,
xuất hạ nửa tình hộng bỏ tuyến, sứng dành người có nhân phẩm tốt nhất bản thiệt.
Cơ hội sau kẻ phủng bí dài để chơi thành chú nhân của các đáp đến một chăm còn lại chỉ giao dài đến hết ngày mối lâm thằng chiến năm,
anh cũng trong hai người làm cùng thu bóng sật bởi vật mài, lực kéo lên tay để sân hai trải nghiệp lời lời chỉ có trong mùa hài này.